foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where that is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth they work that they actually love
and create real amazing relationships
open phones this hour Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author host of the Ken Coleman show is
my co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five and Ken I'm convinced
America should be very afraid right now
uh returning to the phone screening
chair after uh four years after several
years in management yeah and Leadership
is uh the famous Laura yeah Johnson yes
um when she started she was Laura Mays
we used to call her the amazing one and
then we learned better but um oh cold
right out of the gate you just got back
in the control abuse the abuse begins
quickly yeah it's a management tool over
here at Ramsey abuse so fun to see her
over there uh you know she she sat
across the you know across the glass
from me here and like this couldn't talk
back which was wonderful
um for like 13 years yeah and then moved
into uh producing and leading the
production teams here at Ramsey and all
this and today uh because we're in a
holiday week uh we're short-handed and
she's stepped back into her uh her old
talents yeah I she and I she used to uh
oversee me on the video channel when I
first started here I was not a
personality and boy she just gave me all
kinds of grief yeah she would say things
in my ear while I was live on the air
and so she's she's awesome it's good to
see her smiling face she's the OG the
the original right there uh LJ the OG so
it's good to have her in there
well I'm trying hard and every teenager
that's listening
but I asked her how many people had to
not be available for us to to get you
today and it was a lot
yeah yeah
so digging out the bottom yeah Laura
Johnson screening phones today associate
producer for the day uh so she's working
for all the people that work for her
today and that's how it works here at
Ramsey we do what it takes to get her
done open phones triple eight eight two
five five two two five Thomas is in
Florida Hey Thomas welcome to the Ramsey
Show
oh hi I'm glad to be here good how can
we help
uh
well-driven person recently I've been
wondering should I try and work towards
my passion of being a storyboard writer
or should I listen to Michael Rose
advice and find a trade job to help me
become a little bit more profitable then
focus on my passions
well that's a that's a good setup I've
heard a lot of people have approached me
on that and what Mike says and I don't
want you to confuse what he's saying I
think this is probably a both and uh
what is it going to take for you to be a
successful storyboard writer that that
comes down to skills and experience so
what does that Journey look like can you
do that full-time if you cannot support
yourself doing that full-time then maybe
a trade or any other job that that I
would call a day job that allows me to
take care of business and then train get
some experience on the side build the
relationships and get to a place where I
can step from one to the other and I
think the way you said that in that
second class classification is probably
the way to do it but it doesn't have to
be a trade
uh Thomas uh wait a minute let me ask
you something uh I mean we use
storyboard in all our Productions and
things we do here
um
I'm kind of doubting since I know a
little bit about the business that
there's full-time work for a storyboard
writer in Sarasota Springs Florida
well if you're in La Atlanta Nashville
where there's a lot of Film Production
and a lot of uh video production of
things I'm missing something in Sarasota
Springs the center of video and I don't
know it
uh no sir but I was just one thinking
about like maybe moving like somewhere
where the work would be more available
yeah you can get there the question is
what does that look like what's a
successful storyboard writer making do
you know
uh no sir you gotta know like we can't
just kind of go well I'd like to do this
well you know I'd like to dunk a
basketball on a 10-foot Rim it's not
happening
not without a trampoline so how
realistic is it so here's the first
thing you've got to do what what does a
career path look like in that space and
today's point is that a full-time gig if
it's not is it a subsidiary of a writing
position yeah I think you're a content
and creative guy first and foremost I'm
afraid you're niching this out too far
uh I mean you've you've gone this down
to the very nuanced job that a handful
of people in the world have
um and so uh I mean content creation is
in essence what storyboarding is that's
right and you know you're you're you're
you're
helping the production team create a
narrative and a flow through what
they're getting ready to put on film or
tape whatever we want to call it none of
it above digits but anyway the uh uh so
I'm if we were doing that at Ramsey we
would be hiring a creative who also did
yeah
a Content person who also did
um as a matter of fact that's what how
we do it we don't have anybody here that
does that so I'm I'm kind of gonna how
old are you
I am 20 years old sir how did you decide
that storyboard writing was your thing
um because I usually enjoy uh usually
enjoyed like coming up with with
expanding through story lines and coming
up with creative way creative original
ideas and so forth
stay right there what you just said all
right content guy so Thomas what you
just said to us that is a 50 000 foot
view of a job description so you start
with that now the research process is
what are all the different ways that
professionally I can do this work
what are the pathways to all of those
positions then we ask well then what am
I going to have to do to get the
experience and the qualifications to
eventually get there now we have real
answers and again you're 20. I
appreciate the call but you don't know
what you don't know and we've got to go
get answers to those type of things then
the question is all right what is the
best financial path for me to get there
and if picking up a trade and again you
know the trades that we think of blue
collar work but in today's world you can
go to a coding camp and you can get an
I.T trade it pays you very very well
that will give you stability and the
opportunity to acquire these skills on
the site because in the world that we
live in and let's just call it the
content World whether you're a
broadcaster speaker author doesn't
matter that is a much tougher path and
it takes a little bit longer and it is
based on experience experience
experience and many times experience
doesn't pay and so you've got to be
patient and this is a long Hall
potentially if you want to be in that
content space yeah I I think you could
very well end up spending a lot of your
life doing storyboarding at some point
but it's kind of like you called up and
said I not only want to be an actor I
want to be an actor in commercials I
don't really want to be an actor in
commercials I want to be an actor only
on car insurance commercials right and
so I'm going to tell you pan back a
little bit and let's broaden The Horizon
that still encompasses your passion area
and let the storyboarding be a Nuance
within it and I think it'll help you get
there it's a neat call thank you sir we
appreciate you we're honored with your
question thank you this is the Ramsay
show
foreign
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Coleman Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author of the book paycheck
to purpose is my co-host today Brett is
with us Brett is in Charleston South
Carolina hi Brett welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hi thank you both for having me on it's
a pleasure to talk to you sure what's up
so I grew up uh very poor you know often
not even having meals and then as my uh
grew into a senior in high school both
my parents got jobs making six figures
and it seemed like it was so fun eating
out and just living recklessly as a
whole family and then my parents got
divorced everything just kind of fell
apart and I now have been blessed of
owning my own business and making a
pretty considerable salary increase and
I'm finding myself feeling fearful about
the money that I'm making I know I still
have eleven thousand dollars to pay off
on uh baby step two
but I just am kind of afraid of the
effect of money I I just I'm living in
fear and I'm hoping to get some help be
more specific what do you what is it
you're afraid of
you know I just I don't want the
lifestyle of money to be able to to tear
away the things that really matter to me
um you know I don't want it so that
we're just eating out and living you
know like this great life and then some
of the family values kind of go by the
wayside how do you find those values
while earning greater money you know how
do you stay rooted I guess
okay
um
number one I don't think you're gonna
have a problem because you are watching
for it
it's the people that don't watch for it
that um that it gets so you're not
looking to money
to be your salvation
and so it's not going to let you down
people that get in trouble are the ones
that say oh I'll be happy when
and then they're not happy when okay
because money's you know success money
anything's a bully in the schoolyard as
soon as you achieve it and you step
across you know he draws a Line in the
Sand and says if you step across this
line I'm going to punch you and you step
across the line he backs up and draws
another line and says if you step across
this line then I'm really going to punch
you you know and that's what it it's
always moving this I'll be happy when
I'll be happy when I'll be happy when
and those are the people that getting
money gets them off track because they
thought money had a power to do things
it does not have it does not have the
power to give you happiness it does not
have the power to give you Joy it does
not have the power to give you peace it
does not have the power to
uh create values in your family unless
you try to give it that power and then
it will let you down
but you're not going to do that so I'm
really not worried about you
I appreciate you saying that you know
and just a dad of four daughters I just
want to make sure I you know use it to
its best opportunity so like my little
boy you know we finally got a decent car
after we're going bankrupt and uh my
little boy at the time
um is a little guy he's the smallest of
the Ramses right and uh we take we get
them in the finally get a car that's not
got like a dent in it you know I mean
they finally get a decent vehicle and
he's in the back seat and we're doing
the old family drive around the block in
the new car everybody check out the new
car oh we're excited right you know the
routine right and he leans back and he
goes
we're doing pretty good
right and see that's a signal that
there's a problem
and so I just stopped the car and I said
we aren't doing good at all I'm doing
good you got nothing
I'm doing pretty good you you're broke
okay and so you just need to know that's
where you're starting from b-r-o-k-e
Buddy and so um you know and and so
that's in other words we did not allow
money to be the value
of okay now we're okay when we get this
better car oh now we're okay if we get
to move in that house oh now we're okay
if I have a thing a label on my purse or
whatever the crap it is right and so you
know you're just not gonna allow your
family to be defined by this and so
money then become PT Barnum had a
wonderful saying he said money is a
fabulous slave it's a horrible Master
yeah and that's what we're talking about
is who's in charge here you are the
money you're in charge the money's not
so you're not going to fall prey to
these things as long as you keep money
not don't let money be in charge in
anyone's life that is in your purview
your you know your spouse your kids as
for me and my house money is a tool
um it's not the master you see what I'm
doing
yeah yeah I just would I would say this
Brett I can feel the fear on you and
that's why we push you to be specific
and I think you're afraid that more
money and a fluency that comes with that
is going to distract you and tempt you
to do things you don't want to do as
opposed to say no the money I make and
any wealth that comes with that is going
to allow me to do more of what I believe
we should do so I think it's boundaries
setting up those boundaries like Dave
said when do you hear something or see
something or smell something among the
family where it goes that's not right I
want to nip that in the butt and I think
it's setting boundaries and not worrying
about the Temptation if you've got clear
boundaries uh I think you're going to do
more of the right things instead of
doing things that you don't want but you
you grew up hearing and most of us did
uh that that you know rich people are
evil or they're all Crooks or something
like that which is absolute hogwash
it's absolutely it's an absolute it's
asinine it's an absolute lie but it's
the stuff that poor people or hopeless
people say because they're jealous yeah
and and so you know most rich people I
know are no more crooked than the poor
people I know
and they're no more righteous than the
poor people I know you know the amount
of money you have doesn't make you a
crook or righteous
uh it's a character quality so you know
it's a moral money's a morally does not
have morals it just attaches itself to
people who do
um and so yeah you just you got this
message from childhood from the old from
the from the growing up Hood the
neighborhood and you're like you know oh
well I'm afraid I'm going to become one
of those evil rich people and uh then
you discover no I'm just gonna be one of
the good rich people okay good yeah well
I got it I love what you said about the
Daniel story it's one of my favorite
stories it reminds me of something
Shaquille O'Neal said I believe he's
during his Hall of Fame speech but it's
perspective he said to his kids we ain't
Rich I'm rich exactly it's the same
thing you know it's like give the kids
context yeah why do I make this money
what had to happen for us to get to this
place now what do we believe we should
do with money and you give it
perspective you know and then the kids
and everybody else goes okay I get it
but you know here's the thing and and
you show the kids it came from hard work
you show the kids the business is
successful because we're helping a lot
of people that's exactly right and hey
oh I had to struggle you know I tell my
kids all the time like I try to remind
they were little when I first started
after this whole broadcasting thing I
remind them all the time how bad the
first broadcasting things I did were
like they don't even deserve to be drug
out of the ditch the ash heap of History
like you had to do bad stuff you had to
do humble stuff you had to struggle uh
it took time to build like this doesn't
just you don't just show up and do the
things I'm doing today and and my all my
kids understand that you know and by the
way they also understand that if they
want more money they've got to go to
work yeah I don't just keep filling up
their bank account
does not destroy your family values no
he brought up eating out several times
eating out does not yeah I think he was
worried about getting away from the
dinner table which I get that then then
I'll make the dinner table a part of the
family tradition part of our part of our
weekly schedule that is uh three nights
a week five nights a week whatever it is
we are all gathering at the table and uh
no you can't book anything across that
and I don't care what your friends are
doing and this is what we do the other
nights we can go out to eat or you go
out with your buddies or do whatever you
can go to somebody else's house whatever
but these nights were here and if you're
if you want to establish that as a
family tradition a family Rhythm that's
a good thing it is it's a good thing and
if you're going to go ahead and do that
then just no screens at the table by the
way so I agree we'll help you with that
um Dave you're not going to believe this
we made the Coleman kids play Clue last
night and they howled like I was
torturing them and would you believe
that they actually enjoyed it once I got
them into the game and they figured out
how to play it but you would have
thought I was the worst father of all
time you are I don't want to play Clue I
don't want to play how long does it take
I can't hear child abuser make them play
board games it was good they actually
ended up enjoying it imagine that yeah
oh it's Boomer day on the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the
debt free stage Mark is with us hey Mark
how are you fantastic Dave thanks sir
thanks for the introduction I appreciate
it absolutely sir where do you live uh
just outside of Dallas and and Fate
Texas oh yeah okay the Garland area yes
sir yeah cool good to have you man so
how much debt have you paid off I paid
off 323
000 in five and a half years of course
you did wow all right and uh your range
of income during that five and a half
years 112 000 to 166. cool what do you
do for a living uh well I started out as
a wireless network engineer and then
noticed a need for a technical project
manager in that space so I went out and
got some education and transitioned to a
technical project manager nice income in
Greece yeah yeah it was tough um there
was a little a little bit of a dip
um uh but uh what I continued to do is
just rely on my uh technical skills in
the wireless space and uh then I
volunteered to present the status of our
project to to upper management and uh so
it just grew from there and I realized
that there was very few people that
could uh communicate technically
speaking and and and then work as a as a
project manager so
um and I did that during my debt-free uh
debt-free Journey wow how long was that
dip that you just described uh it took
probably about eight months but um so I
was relying on my wireless network
skills as an engineer fixing problems
and then like I said just really uh
volunteered to present the status to to
folks did some PowerPoint presentations
and so I've I've combined my technical
skills with project management skills
and it's offering what I've discovered
is it offers a unique skill set that a
lot of people people don't have right
now I love that story right there Dave
this is a guy who goes all right I want
to make some changes and you took the
dip but you didn't slow down you didn't
accept it now you got the big pay bump
yeah that helped accelerate the journey
I really love that story yeah thanks Ken
I appreciate that
um hats off to you too you you and I
have a little bit of History you took my
call the last uh on the last uh caller
February 2nd uh 2022 I was in a pretty
dark place uh at you know during my
journey and and it was you and and uh
um uh uh Ken and and George you guys
took my calling and that really uh
inspired me uh a bit uh very cool that's
awesome what kind of debt was your 323
000. Dave I had everything I had student
loans I had uh car loans I had credit
cards I had outdoor cameras in fact I
think if I remember correctly they were
lining up cheetahs to join the field
um and but I tell you what we might want
to call some animal people get the
Cheetahs some help because they're not
looking too good back there yeah yeah
getting a little uh getting a little
thin yeah not having enough to eat these
days yeah cool yeah so you were normal
though you collected every kind of debt
yeah rental properties included okay wow
yeah what what do you attribute what do
you tell people that you the secret to
getting out of that is I mean 323
thousand dollars dude that's how that's
high cotton yeah I mean it was uh five
thousand dollars a month for 63 months
um for me it was
um the moment that I walked into my
master bathroom
I just remember that there was there was
a period there where I I said I have a
mess
I I can't retire
and I need to figure out how I'm going
to do this I'm 50 I was 50 years old at
that point
um and
um so I just I had to I had to clean up
my mess yeah had to figure it out I mean
and so you had I had kind of an oh crap
I've had it moment yeah and then what
did you do how'd you get tied into us
well so I listened to your uh uh radio
station I was working um a second shift
I would get off at seven o'clock or 6 30
drive home and I have a tendency to
listen to the news on the radio on the
way home so I don't have to constantly
listen to the same recirculated stories
over and over again when I get home so I
was thumbing through the am radios
landed on your station or your your
radio replay and um that's what got me
inspired in 2014 that was 2014. I joined
Financial Peace University at that point
um and didn't finish it it was a 13-week
long course
um with the with the kit and I didn't
finish it but the seed the seed had been
planted and I knew
in 2016 I I had to I was at a point
where I just had to do something the
final moment for me was happened in in
March of 2016 and April I uh we had a
really bad hail storm and it caused my
rental properties to
uh have a claim have claims opened up on
it and then I hit 50 years old I was
like I went ahead and I paid that put it
on the credit card for the for the
deductibles and then hit 50 years old
said man I got a real problem a week
later we had a second hail storm that
required a second claim that and and
that hail storm eventually ended up
causing about forty two thousand dollars
on uh of damage on my rental properties
and so
it took me six months seven months and I
remember in November November uh 2016. I
walked into that bathroom and just
looked at myself and
it was it was as if nobody existed in
the world it was just me my raw emotions
and the person looking in that mirror
and
I just said I need to figure this out I
there's no one else here that I can
count on I need to do this and
um the next day I sold all of my ins
Employee Stock purchase plan thirty five
thousand dollars of Cisco stock
sold that and paid off my credit card
one of my credit cards and I had an 80
20 loan on one of my rental properties I
paid off the 20 of that wow yeah you
killed it man congratulations thank you
sir how's it feel to be free oh my gosh
I mean the world I I've just recently
told people that I'm a 55 year old
infant
so hey we got a copy of Total Money
Makeover for you a copy of the baby
steps millionaires book a one-year
membership to Financial Peace University
all in the live and give bundle and
that's the thing that you'll be able to
do is give most of that away you've been
through most of it but I think you're on
the track to be a baby steps millionaire
also um there's rumors going around here
at Ramsey and sometimes there's rumors
going around here they're always good
rumors when they go around here that
you've been working extremely hard and
that you've been very very very
dedicated towards you really had a
desire to become a financial coach yeah
a Ramsey Financial coach and so Tim Mann
with the coaching team
is going to come join you here on the
stage Tim I'll let you take it for a
second yeah I just I'm so excited to
watch your progress over the last year
to see how you have jumped in repeatedly
inside of FPU inside of Financial Peace
University participating in group
coaching encouraging others challenging
others and also seeking out how do I
become a financial coach I think you've
been on what a dozen of our financial
Coach master training webinars and
workshops and just watching your growth
and progress I'm just really excited to
let you know we're going to bring you in
no charge Financial Coach master
training on us we are so excited to have
you you are what we're looking for in
coaching you're the guy who is the
encourager you're the guy who's going to
share your story you're the guy who's
going to continue to bring other people
along in this journey and we could not
be any prouder of you mark thanks Tom
you have an incredible
very cool
that's pretty fun Dave I gotta I gotta
you have an incredible family here an
incredible team they
um they are part of my extended family
and going through this um that's what we
heard I think going through this single
as a single person Tim and his team
um I'm standing here because of the
inspiration that they gave me across to
over those phone calls and now you get
to pay it forward yeah absolutely and if
I can share anything just um the feeling
I want to pass along the feeling that I
have on that last payment knowing and
watching that last payment clear
um I want others to feel that amen I
want to I want people to lean into their
debt own it and drive it and and solve
it and I want you to get your debt free
scream in all right here we go Tim thank
you Mark from Garland Texas 323
000 paid off in five and a half years
making 112 to 166 future Certified
Financial coach from Ramsey count it
down let's hear a debt free scream three
two one in Jesus Christ I'm dead friend
hey yo
wow
we sort of we train people to be
Financial coaches for those of you who
don't know and the training is a wee bit
expensive to go through it but uh Mark
he's a special guy this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today
one of the keys to becoming successful
with money is learning the Art and
Science of generosity building your
generosity muscle so every year we
always do a giving show at Christmas
time to highlight the power of
generosity and we need you to help us
with the giving show by being on the
show telling your giving or receiving
story someone gave to you and changed
your life someone you were able to give
and it was a rock star moment and it'll
Inspire other people to be generous by
hearing your story we need three hours
worth of those we're gonna do the show
on December the 14th so we'll be calling
you on that day and we need you to send
an email in tell us a little bit about
the story and the team will be in touch
with you and get you lined up and all so
you email to ask
at ramseysolutions.com the name ask at
ramseysolutions.com just put giving in
the subject line or something like that
and uh we'll help you be part of the
upcoming giving show and Ken for the
Black Friday coming up we got a deal on
the get clear assessment that's right um
I don't know why this is a deal it
shouldn't be a deal because it's a deal
and this thing's a deal without making
it a deal yeah well you get it just this
week for twenty dollars it's ten dollars
off the normal price and this is a tool
that's going to help anybody who's not
where they want to be professionally
maybe you're on the right track uh but
you feel like you should be getting
promoted maybe a little bit quicker
you're trying to get that breakthrough
maybe you have no idea what you want to
do maybe you're looking for that idea
for a side Hustle the idea is how can I
find uh purpose and work and then make
the income that I want and this tool
does it for you it's the get clear
career assessment and uh it's it's a
wonderful wonderful tool only 2 20 bucks
normally thirty dollars yeah and the
paycheck to purpose number one
best-selling book ten dollars right now
and baby steps millionaires my latest
number one best seller ten dollars wow
which makes all of my books now
available at only ten dollars it's
ridiculous there's inflation out there
would you approve of this station
makes me feel cheap right it makes you
feel cheap when you buy it for just ten
dollars it's a deal ten people for 100
bucks you knock out their gifts right
there boom just like that
ramsaysolutions.com Black Friday deals
on gifts that actually matter legilla is
with us legill is in Detroit Hello Jill
how are you
hi Dave hi Ken hey hi what's up
I'm so so
um I I am
and
um I'm like a Serial entrepreneur so
like I bring in a lot of money a lot of
different ways but my question is
um should I well I'm paying off debt
should I focus on like just the business
I have that makes me money instead of
putting out money for my other
businesses to make money if that makes
sense
how many are making money
so like okay for example I throw like
parties I'm an event planner so I maybe
spend like 1200 but I'll make a couple
Grand
but I don't know if I should be putting
that money out to do that
you spend 1200 and you make thirty two
hundred
profit of a couple Grand
right that's debt you're paying off
every time you do that all right I mean
so profit is profit yeah I mean you're
not you're not spending the money and
it's not coming back it's coming back to
you instantaneously almost isn't it
yeah it comes back to well the daily
party yeah a couple months later yeah
okay so which business is which that
one's not losing money
well I have like I have like
um like social media type stuff and
that's the stuff that doesn't
necessarily make me money right here and
now and then I also do like drawing and
logos and stuff and
that that makes me money when people
like ask for it but I don't know if I
should really get into like the
full-on advertising and content creating
side of things oh I should just wait for
all that type of stuff you should you
should wait to expand right now you just
want to do things that make you money so
you get out of baby step too fast
quick as possible right so we can delay
the stuff that you want to maybe expand
one day once we're in a position to do
so
five years from today do you want to be
in the logo business or the event
planning business
do I want to be a number planning
you want to be an event planning or
logos which one
you've been planning okay start doing
that now then
quit screwing around with 17 things
you get no power when you don't Focus
I would focus on I'd focus on event
planning and blow it up
put all your time all your energy all
your effort all your creative waking
hours into one thing uh working three
different businesses is a recipe for
getting none of them off the ground
okay well I also so my main source of
income is actually like grocery delivery
where I do like chip instacart type
things and I'm I make pretty actually
make pretty good money doing that okay
but that's not that's not what we're
talking about that's that's a stop Gap
until the event business gets big enough
that you don't have to do that anymore
right yeah so if you're making a hundred
thousand dollars a year doing event
planning you wouldn't be doing any of
this other crap
very true okay
okay I would I'm gonna send you a copy
I'm gonna send you a copy of a quick
read we have
called the momentum theorem
and the momentum theorem is this focused
intensity
over time
multiplied by God creates Unstoppable
momentum
and this book will take you about an
hour and a half to read Max
okay and it explains exactly what this
focused intensity looks like and you
have the exact opposite of that you have
dispersed intensity which has no power
to it
the more I feel regardless light
dispersed lights of room light Focus you
can do surgery with it's called a laser
and I want you to be laser
and you're going to move this business
into the stratosphere when you do
because you got so much energy on you
there's so much joy coming off of you
you you you're like the ultimate event
planner this is going to be great oh
yeah and again you have a side hustle
that's actually spinning off real profit
that's where you put your focus right
now we're trying to generate income to
get out of debt get the emergency fund
in place and that changes your entire
perspective so I mean this is the focus
here is absolutely the word you know
trying to do too many things is
exhausting too oh yeah you know on top
of everything else it's enough to get
out of debt you don't need all these
other distractions
it's a little bit of the problem we've
got with a whole bunch of things in our
culture today people's inability to keep
their eye on the ball to stay and play
through to have some grit to stick with
something all the way through and finish
it up and um you know I want work life
balance but I want to spend 40 hours a
week on my screens so no I think you
need to get off your stupid screens and
uh actually look in the eyes of your
family actually be present physically
with your family
um and then not wonder why relationships
are bad because you're not because you
suck at them right and then one of the
things that we see in in this case here
is is we Prospect as opposed to digging
deep like we're going to invest right
it's like our investment strategy that
you've taught for decades it's slow and
steady wins the race it's disciplined
yeah but you're drill into the core
we're not just skimming the surface
that's right none of this process we're
not strip mining right and so the serial
entrepreneurs can fall prey to that to
go well I'm going to try this because
this could strike but I'm going to do
this and hedge my bets over here maybe
this will strike and as opposed to
digging deep to get that oil like we're
going to commit and go deep and that's
where you see long-term success
financially relationally your health
everything the reason I can smell this
out is because I used to do it right
like I mean I'm 23 years 24 years old
buying real estate like crazy hand over
fist and I almost in the middle of all
of that Finance 25 000 worth of
quarter machines to put at the market to
pump air into your tires yeah when they
first started charging for air
I thought it was the dumbest thing in
the world and I thought this is going to
work and I almost stopped what I was
doing because I'm a Serial entrepreneur
and add as I can be right and stopped
doing a successful real estate thing
that was working and went and bought air
machines that's how dumb I am yeah by
the way those things never work when I
need air can never get one that works
Dave I don't know about that bought my
own machine not my fault because I
didn't buy it so you have to turn turn
your complaint into the department you
don't need right really wow hey folks if
you like the show please consider
subscribing leaving a review and sharing
it with a friend it makes all the
difference in the world it lights up the
things called the internet we love it
when you do that subscribe to the show
leave a review a five star review and
share it with a friend thank you this is
the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
all of our shows with the Ramsay Network
app on your smartphone it's the only
place to listen to the entire back
catalog of episodes download the Ramsay
Network app in your favorite app store
today
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsey show but that is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thank you
for joining us America the phone number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five Ken Coleman Ramsay personality
number one best-selling author of the
book paycheck to purpose and host of the
Ken Coleman show talking about your jobs
your careers is my co-host today open
phones triple eight eight two five five
two two five Amanda's with us in Fort
Worth hi Amanda how are you
Hi how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up good
um I need I am needing your help to
solve an argument between my husband and
I about paying off our mortgage okay
so um he's retired and he's 66 and I'm
still working I'm 63.
um we don't have any debt except for our
mortgage uh we owe a hundred thousand on
it
um we're wanting to take money out of
our 401 or he's wanting to take money
out of 401 to pay the balance of the of
the mortgage but I've always I always
agree with that paying off the mortgage
but now it's since we've lost so much
money in our 401 then I know if we take
it out then then it's considered really
losing it so I just wanted your opinion
[Music]
okay
um so you're not arguing as to whether
to do this you're arguing whether this
now or wait on the market to come back
up
yeah exactly okay
so that's the only question is the
timing not the actual action
oh yeah we definitely want to do it okay
and how much is in the 401K
uh it was four hundred thousand now it's
300.
and we owe a hundred thousand on the
house
um and it's a 300 000 house but we
probably have about forty thousand we
can put towards in cash we can put
towards it too so it would be sixty
thousand coming out of it sounds like
you're invested very poorly the market
is not down 25 percent
well we're always uh Marcus down 15 to
12 to 15 percent
now I don't know if we've lost a hundred
thousand in the last two years not one
year but
so I probably need to check on it again
we are with an investor Pro
but we probably need to check on it
again with a smart investor bro okay
um yeah
um
what do you make
uh seventy thousand
it's on the bubble for me okay here's
why all right if you told me you had
four million in there I'd tell you stop
your whining and just write a check
today okay
um if you had a hundred thousand or if
you had 200 000 in there and you're
gonna put 100 out and it's only going to
leave you 100 I'll tell you don't do it
let's wait and Whittle away at it and
pay it down out of your income okay but
you're kind of in the middle
and uh with 400 or 300 in there you're
kind of you're gonna have a good amount
still left in the nest egg do you have
other Investments other than this 401
uh that 401 is a view a couple of 401s
mine and my husband you can't touch her
how old are you
I'm 63. oh you're 63.
behind he's 67. okay so both of you can
get at it okay so uh that's the total of
all your retirement then
yes
yes
okay
I you know I either one's okay I I
really can't help you with solving the
argument
um what I what Sharon and I would do in
this case is
um we we would probably kind of meet in
the middle and that would be okay I'm
gonna I'm willing to wait on it to come
back up some
but not just this indefinite weird thing
so I'm gonna like put a number on it
when the account returns to X we're
taking the money out and paying off the
mortgage
okay and I don't care what that is I
mean if you make it 423 000 right
whatever when the when the account hits
423 that day we're taking 100 out and
paying off the house
and just to be in agreement on the
number instead of this vague thing of oh
the stock market emotions right and all
that stuff right we don't want to get in
that game
um
so that that would be the gameplay even
our like 1100 that we make payments we
can start putting that back in the
market too you know so that's kind of
what we're thinking so you could do it
today it's not going to cause you to
bankrupt it's not going to cause you to
not eat at retirement you could do it
today but if you want to ride uh to your
point the market is down do we want to
try to ride it back up a little I'm not
much on time in the market I don't like
that uh in general but I kind of get it
to a point so if it's me I'm gonna say
all right when it gets to a certain
point and I don't care what that is it's
375. y'all talk it through but I'm
somewhere 375 four and a quarter or
something like that then that day I'm
cashing it out and we're both in
agreement and the argument's over
is the 40 cash you said you could throw
it is that above and beyond your
emergency fund yes we'll go and throw
that out I would do that for sure now
it's less money you're pulling out of
the 401K when that time comes yeah good
point and you know what might happen you
might just beat the crap out of the
thing out of your income and your budget
with only 60 left and just knock it out
and not even hit the 401.
that's true too okay that could happen
before it comes back up to your magic
number you come up with right
yeah but but the trick here the
beautiful thing about the the the issue
is it doesn't really matter either way
you go on this
um what matters mostly is that you get
in agreement
and you get unified and then that puts
both of your shoulder to the plow again
and it starts to starts the plow moving
again right now we're just circling and
running around and you know uh arguing
about it and so
um
so let's just decide what it is put a
number on it throw the 40 at it start
beating it on it on and out of the
budget and when it returns to that
number if you hadn't knocked it out
finish it off that day yeah yeah that's
and given that that we just put 40 on
there there's only 60 left I'm I think
that motivates me to knock the 60 out
I'm gonna be real tempted to do it now
but I'm also gonna if not I'm gonna
lower the number that's the magic number
yes I might take it back all the way
back down to 350 or something I'm gonna
I want to get two or 360. let's say
there's 300 left over after we take the
money out right or you gotta pay taxes
so 370 whatever but uh some you know
let's just decide something like that
um
and
and then get there or
when the balance is equal to the amount
over 300 I'm making all this I just like
to have some kind of little set
objective thing that Sharon and I no
longer have an argument now so the
decision's already made it's a matter of
when it gets there it's executed boom
yeah you know here Amanda you Dave gave
you great advice I will tell you my
personal opinion is I hate paying taxes
so much that I I would pay the 40 today
and then I'd knock the 60 out I just
don't want to take I don't want to take
the tax hit on the 401K even though it's
a viable option it just drives me nuts
Dave to take a hit so I'd want to just
cash flow and pay the 60 off it wouldn't
hurt anything no wouldn't hurt anything
and then it's coming back your 401k is
going to get back there yeah so and the
good news is not 600. and the good news
is they got options and the good news is
Dave they both want to pay the house off
so that's a nice thing to be unified
none really really really good work
excellent excellent job
this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Dr John deloney is on Jordan Peterson's
podcast this week and YouTube show it's
aired starting yesterday
a long-form interview hour and some
change and uh the two of them together
is way more brain cells than I care to
think about in one place but uh it's
it's incredible I I listened to it
watched it all the way through and it is
absolutely amazing go check it out
um again Jordan Peterson and Dr John
deloney together talking about childhood
trauma marriage making friends all the
types of things that John talks about on
the Dr John deloney show pretty
regularly Black Friday sales are here
don't get squashed by people running to
the Bargain Bin head to the Ramsey head
to ramsesolutions.com them get early
access to some of our lowest prices of
the year the team has even marked prices
down as low as seven dollars all audio
book gift cards are seven dollars this
week only whoa that includes even the
new book baby steps millionaires all our
books are read by the authors by the way
and uh so you can pick them up the audio
books are Pretty stinking incredible
good way to make a car ride or an
airplane ride go faster too audio uh
book gift cards along with tons more
items seven dollars this is a season to
share the hope we have with people we
care about uh this is uh gifts that
matter right so these deals are great
way to do it do the hard thing share
your experience and give them something
meaningful this book by Ken Coleman
helped me get a job this book by Dr John
deloney helped me with my anxiety this
book by Rachel Cruz or Dave Ramsey
helped me with my money and so on right
there we go so check it all out at
ramseysolutions.com Black Friday deals
are starting now right
mcsolutions.com do not miss this
Justin's with us Justin's in Tampa
Florida hi Justin how are you
hey how you doing Dave
better than I deserve how can I help
um so my question is me and my wife have
been doing our finances and I've come to
notice that she has a credit card
spending issue and I thought maybe we
should get a smaller amount credit card
to help so that she can't spend so much
is this going to solve anything or is
this just a bad idea all around
um I I don't think she has a credit card
spending issue I think you have a
household Vision issue
yeah I can agree the two of you don't
have a big enough vision for your future
that you're willing to uh pay the price
to do and instead we're acting like
little children and buying whatever we
want whenever we want it which is what
most Americans do and that's why most
people are broke
and so you need a bigger Vision I want
to change my family tree I want to be
able to travel I want to be able to
drive a car that's not a piece of crap
that I pay cash for I want to be able to
whatever I want to be able to be
outrageously generous to people
especially this time of year I'm
activated on to do all that and we're
too dead gum broke because our money
processes and our money habits suck and
so we need a bigger Vision that we're
both willing to give up our bad habits
to get to the bigger vision and then the
credit cards just go away
because they don't they're not included
in a big vision of people who want to
win with money you just get debit cards
you don't need a credit card
gotcha saving put it away yeah just the
whole thing goes away I mean you need to
chop them all up and have an emergency
fund and have a budget and be working
your way out of debt and you sound like
you're fairly new to our stuff
yes sir okay yes sir all right I'll send
you a Christmas present you and your
wife look at it it's called The Total
Money Makeover and it walks you through
a detailed Proven Plan step by step on
what you can do to get control of your
money get you some money habits that
work but you're treating the symptom
you're not training the problem yeah and
he knew that I think he just needed to
hear someone else say it you know I'm
going to limit your undisciplined
as opposed to Let's remove the lack of
discipline yeah that's what we want to
attack but no one does discipline for
discipline's sake no gotta have a big
picture yeah I don't want to lose weight
reasons right you know or whatever it is
for this yeah that's right yeah
uh open phone's a triple eight eight two
five five two two five Daniels with us
Daniel is in Atlanta Georgia how are you
Daniel I'm good how you guys doing today
better than we deserve what's up all
right but I kind of wanted some general
wisdom from you since you're a business
owner
um we run a small business and these
it's a family business and I wanted to
know how you would apply your basic
budgeting principles at home to a
business kind of sort of
um to operate cash on cash only bases
kind of and
stuff like that is what I'm looking for
so okay what kind of business have you
got it's a construction trade business
um we've been in business for about 17
years but it's kind of what you say we
work harder than smart we work hard but
we outwork our stupidity basically I
kind of think what kind of construction
are you doing
glasswork residential so you're
subcontractors yeah we're subcontractors
for Builders and homeowners and
remodelers so okay
um
we work we work with construction people
all over the United States and Ontario
leadership all right and I grew up in
the construction business real estate
business so
um you and me are from the same people
okay you're my people yeah yeah and so
uh here's what normally happens I don't
know if it happened at your place but
normally we got a guy who is really good
at a trade in your case glass
okay and then they decide oh I'm going
to open a glass business I'm going to
own the thing
and now you're still really good at
class but you don't have business skills
yeah which is what you're asking me for
yeah my dad he was very much a
technician which yep so speaking of all
that stuff you know he was very
technician like which he recommended a
book to you recommended a book the email
by Michael Gerber which is I listened to
it while I'm driving around and I
finished it and it runs true with a lot
of things that are going on right now
yep you're working in the business
you're not working on yeah yeah so one
main thing I need to do so the way you
do a budget is number one there's a
subset in your world but the way you do
a budget is overall uh you plan out what
your income is going to be this coming
month
and that's fairly easy to do because
you've got most of the jobs on the books
and in the pipeline so you kind of know
what we're going to get jobs we're going
to get paid on this month and we look at
our expenses for the month and the
difference is called profit
and you do that go ahead would you do
that based off of what actually came in
or would you do that off of what is
expected to come in because there's a
budget the budget is a projection yeah
then the actual management against
budget is if we're above budget we've
got more profit if we're below budget we
got less profit mm-hmm okay and so but
we in no case go borrowing money because
we didn't do any projections and we're
living we're pulling this out of our ear
all the time
yeah making it up every Friday yeah very
stressful it's very stressful no no it's
good so that's the main thing is
creating some creating time to maybe do
a forecast I think that's probably the
first thing but it really it's going to
take several hours the first time you do
it then it's going to take an hour the
second time you do it and then it's
going to take 30 minutes the third time
you do it there's not a lot to this
another subset in your world is you
probably ought to look at it for an app
or some Builder software that helps you
job cost and you run a profit and loss
statement on each job
yeah so you estimate the job because you
guys do an estimate and turn in a bid
probably right yeah well not really I
mean we do we use QuickBooks right now
and we have our own Excel program that
gives us our I mean you have to give the
contractor a price right yeah
yeah we do but half the time right now
they just go with whatever we give them
these days
um to be honest but we do have a general
we have a margin that we work off of so
that's you know we do have to do a bid
so yes okay so you do a bid and you've
got a margin and then you go back and
look did you actually hit that margin or
not or do you just go on and act like
nothing happened when you screwed it up
we no we you got to revisit that's on
try to get a check and then keep on
pushing so but you could have lost money
and you it wouldn't ever you would never
know to adjust your next estimate if you
don't go back and visit the last
estimate versus actual yeah she got a
job cost and every job is a is its own p
l in other words and did we make money
on that and it takes 10 seconds to look
at it if you put the if you put the
information in so
um it sounds like you probably need to
Outsource some bookkeeping and you need
to put some job costing software on your
phones and and then start living by
these numbers because this is going to
catch you when this Market slows down
Buffett says when the tide goes out you
can tell it was skinny dipping and the
Glass businesses gold business right now
but it might not be in three months
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality
best-selling author of the book paycheck
to purpose is my co-host today the phone
number here is triple eight eight two
five five two two five so Ken I was
listening to our friend Mike Rose
podcast the other day and he had an
author on Nick eberstott or everstat I
don't know if I don't know how to
pronounce it but um I should have
listened to Mike pronounce it because
with his wonderful pipes it was a great
job of pronouncing it right but but uh
you know Mike has been sounding the same
alarm that you and I have been sounding
particularly you that
um we have a uh what you were saying at
the break is a social crisis evolving
and it's showing up in the unemployment
numbers when we properly
measure them now uh this economist is a
mathematician that did this book uh how
things work uh was the I guess that's
Mike's podcast uh we'll see the name of
his book off the top of my head somebody
handed it to me the other day at an
event that's Men at Work if I'm not
mistaken something along with the uh uh
the essence of their discussion that you
and I have been having a similar
discussion is this um uh shift in the
workplace right now that uh
we've got a large number of jobs
available and no one applying for them
there's a shortage of labor for the
first time in post-war or to America
we've never seen this in modern America
and the reason there's a shortage is not
because the jobs are so plentiful it's
because there are according this article
from Fox News quoting micro and quoting
this economist there are now 7 million
able-bodied males
between 25 and 40 years old that are
able to work and are not even looking
for work yeah that's correct and it's
it's staggering and so the point here is
is that uh what's going on this is
causing massive economic problems before
we look at the social very quick glance
here when you have a gap in the jobs
like we've had now for the last two
years then you've got real small
businesses being hurt by this think
about the restaurants in your small town
they can't find people to work and it's
affecting their livelihood then the
other economic factor is of course we
saw and we still see a war for talent
and so wages have gone up tremendously
in the last two years which has now led
to a stubborn inflationary period that
we were in now that's the economic piece
the social piece what's crazy about this
is is that you've got
um 6.8 million people that last last
month according to the latest jobs
report and the Census Bureau a hundred
million Americans weren't working last
month now half of 100 million 100 100
million but half were working no I've
got hold on no we don't have a hundred
million unemployed there's only 300
million the whole students say they were
unemployed I'm saying just not working
period I'm just breaking the numbers
down oh yeah
half are retired okay okay another 12
percent are dealing with some type of
long-term illness so they're or
disability okay and then 5.6 million
people saying I don't want to go back to
work because they're scared of covid and
then the number is right at 7 million
that are saying I don't want to work and
those are the men so the social Factor
that's going on here is you've got two
factors one you've had decades and
Decades of entitlements starts with
welfare and then if you look at during
covet where people were getting payments
every week every month all right so
that's that's an entitlement where
they're disincentivized to actually go
back to work and then Dave I think the
fact that for decades we've we've
literally
taken the pain away from our kids we've
removed the struggle and I don't say
this with Jess but I think when you look
at things like everybody gets a trophy
for participation and nobody learns The
Sting of failure nobody learns The Sting
of rejection so what happens is a good
amount of the seven million men not all
of them are in this conversation that
Mike had with this economist are looking
at screens based on the data they say
how much time they spend on screens they
get dope thousands two thousand year
hours a year two thousand hours seven
million men 25 to 54 are spending 2 000
hours a year so self-medicating because
they're scared to leave the cave using
your old analogy not cave it's Mother's
basement right but the idea is they're
afraid to put themselves out there and
here's what we know about work so when
someone succeeds in work their
self-esteem goes up two they have
Financial Independence or the
opportunity for Financial Freedom and
then three they're part of something
bigger than themselves it's a sense of
belonging Dr John deloney will tell you
your mental health goes up because your
dignity your autonomy that's it your
ability to control your environment goes
up there is such a
uh mental illness tie-in no question
caused by not working that's right uh
literally the so this idea that you have
not put gravel in the stomach of your
kids they have no grit means as a parent
you suck
and so you mommies need to throw your 25
year old out of his out of your basement
yesterday and uh put him on the street
and teach him to work you're late to the
party but you need to do this you are
doing him a disservice you are doing
America a disservice you are doing your
neighbors a disservice you're doing the
Mental Health Community a disservice
you're risking his increased likelihood
of depression anxiety and suicide that's
exactly right you are you are doing all
of these things because you're letting
Junior play Call of Duty 2 000 hours a
year in your basement and he ain't ever
been called to any Duty yeah and the
irony is is you're doing all of that
under the guise of helping your kid feel
good about themselves and the very thing
that they need to feel good about
themselves is to go out and do good it's
the wussification of America yeah yeah
it's just a bunch of wussies yeah is
what it amounts to and you know
seriously a good cowboy boot in the butt
of this whole thing would be helpful it
really really would it just pisses me
off I mean this is just a thing where
you just need to work oh my God seven
million and they saw they call them men
in this article I'll call them males
all right males 25 50 25 to 40 7 million
of them literally sitting on their butts
and someone else is caring for them the
government uh their mommy
their living girlfriend
who thinks she's cute
um here's the breakdown Sugar Mama do
you buddy here's a uh here's some of the
census day to day from a Bloomberg
article the equivalent of 32 million
people who aren't working are relying on
savings that includes retirement okay uh
another 26 million are using credit
cards or loans and 12 million have been
following the credit card is the devil
it's at the center of the problem there
it is and then here's the but here's the
part we've been talking about 12 million
have said that they're borrowing from
family or friends to help keep them out
of the workforce yeah they're living off
family and friends you're enablers
you're giving a drunk a drink you're
giving a lazy person the ability to
still be lazy you're giving someone
who's in avoidance mode because they're
afraid they're scared they're Paralyzed
by the facing or reality and stepping
into the real world when the best thing
that can happen to you the most alive
you'll ever feel is when you risk it and
you step up to the plate and the ball
comes twizzing across and scares the
piss out of you while you swing the bat
this is the best thing that can happen
to you when you strike out right and
it's okay right sometimes it doesn't
work out oh
well I think the the simplest way to
look at what David says remember all of
us when we rode a bike the first time we
were terrified horrified maybe I'm
terrified right now yeah but what
happened like we took that fear we
stepped into it we learned to ride the
bike and it wasn't much longer before we
were saying look Mom no hands we go from
terrified to get on the bike to look Mom
no hands and that's the human Spirit the
idea of these kids these men I shouldn't
say kids but some of them are emotional
and kids they need to feel alive and the
way you feel alive is by making a
contribution for yourself and for
brothers you don't feel alive where
there's no risk well that's exactly
right and coddling the coddling of the
American male the wussification of this
culture it is really starting to be a
social problem it started out as a
parenting problem it started out as this
and hey man I don't know do we
now I'm just gonna blame you moms and
dads well I would say the friends and
the parents are absolutely you know I
can blame Call of Duty if you want but
moms and dads that are good moms and
dads rip that crap out of the wall and
say get your butt out and mow the grass
here's one other one we the people
taxpayers we gotta quit giving these
morons and money to sit on their butts
no more government entitlements that's
where we the people can do something
it's just not good for the [ __ ] it's
not good for the government and it's not
good for us
okay really oh my gosh Dave's like the
soundtrack to all my policies
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for joining us America open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Mike is in Eau Claire
Wisconsin Ken Coleman is my co-host
today Ramsay personality hey Mike how
are you
good Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
uh so my wife and I are on baby steps
four through six we got through the
first three over the last 22 months good
um
thanks
um so my question is a little bit of a a
fomo question
um we have forty thousand dollars left
on our house but with the market on such
a
a stark downturn I'm wondering if I
shouldn't take that 15 that I should be
putting towards the house and possibly
invest that in
um you know mutual funds or an S P 500
Index Fund or something like that nope
it's got It's kind of like the blue
Market special that you hear the Blue
Light Special you've been talking about
yeah I'm not trying to time the market
in that regard I'm just trying to get
people to not pull money out of the
market sure no you need you need to pay
off your house dude okay
easy enough yeah I'm the the market will
always be there it'll always be up and
it'll always be down you got plenty of
time you got plenty of time right now we
want to finish this up and have no house
payments because I got to tell you right
when you when you you what you don't
anticipate is when you pay that very
last bill and you don't have a single
debt in the world your house is paid for
you're you're you're physically gonna
feel this when you push that button
sure and that's way different than just
taking advantage of a Down Market
and it just it's such it just well
there's this thing that happens set you
free done again it does and again this
is the long game that we're talking
about right like if you just think about
that feeling multiplied by decades uh
the Financial Freedom the emotional
Freedom all of that plays out and it's
just a priority issue I don't think you
can argue that at all don't get
distracted again this is a distraction
and I appreciate the question you know
Say Hey I want to take advantage because
he's going the markets down this is a
good time to to to to jump in and that's
why we tell you to stay not put it in
but stay don't pull the money out but
yeah you can't argue the long game yeah
oh you know stick these systems that
we've put in place work are and are case
studied out and modeled out for 30 years
10 million people have done them uh for
up times and down times for inflationary
cycles for recessionary Cycles all these
different things gas prices are five
dollars or two dollars it it's the only
systems that work in all times
and um and yeah inflation's scary and
yeah the market being down scary and
yeah Market van Downs tempting to put
money in I get all of that but just stay
the course just stay the course just
stay the course just slow and steady
wins the race tortoise beats the hair
every time Lydia is in Atlanta hi Lydia
how are you
I'm good how are you Dave better than I
deserve what's up
thanks for taking my call sure so this
is more of an ethical question
my husband I'm calling on behalf of my
husband he is committed to working at a
particular company for five years he's
in year four of it
um he meanwhile has created a business
that has taken off and is providing
everything that we need
but he's been working that business
after he works his full-time job which
takes a lot of time and commitment
and lots of time away from his family
he would like to quit his full-time job
a year early
so that's where that comes to a
five-year deal
I know that's weird
and this is all verbal there was no
contract it was kind of off the cuff
he was being rehired at this place
because he quit for a year and a half
pursuing something else
and he came back and he wanted a
five-year Commitment if he was going to
rehire him
so at that point he didn't have what is
he making it was he making it a side gig
profit
I don't mind because we have lots of
people who listen he know us so right so
nobody knows as much though oh my gosh
okay well um the the question I have
here is beyond the verbal hey if I
rehire you I want you to commit for five
years was there anything else tied to
the conversation obviously there's no
contract so there's no legal issue here
this is just how do you want to leave
because he wants to leave and you want
him to leave well to the extent that you
can so what else was committed to Beyond
just hey will you come back and and give
me five years was that basically the the
in and out of it I I think it was
will hire you back at what you what you
were making when you quit has he done
very well over the last four years for
this company
yes and how's his relationship with his
current leader or the ultimate boss
it's good it's very good he's he's
worked there he had worked there for a
really long time it was the exception
about a year and a half break so he's
worked there for a long time we highly
respect a lot of people that work there
and that's the biggest thing he's afraid
of is losing a lot of that respect well
reputation means I think this is
man-to-man conversation exactly you go
in you sit down you tell the truth yeah
okay listen I gave you my word I gave
you my word that I would be here five
years
and I'm going to ask you to release me
from that obligation because I I'm ready
I'm ready to go huh
you did have this conversation oh and
what did they say and
and he it was brought up
but you committed you gave me your word
you would be here for five years
what's he what what but there's
something beyond the word I get it but
what is his position what is that leader
worried about if he leaves
what what specifically is the holdup
because it's a hard position to replace
someone in and would take some time and
training to get someone to that point
um but he's just he's so stressed out
about it and
oh there's no reason to be stressed out
about it you make a decision and the
stress is over and the decision is
you're going to stay or the decision
that you're going to go it's over yeah
um either one either way I mean just
make a decision that's the stress is
coming from the ambivalence
the the indecisiveness and he doesn't he
doesn't want to be unliked he doesn't
want people to bash him but I don't know
how much of that you can control
um you did he did give his word right
your husband I think I think he stays
for a year
I think he finishes well you got to
honor your word is what I'm saying but I
gotta I gotta I gotta work around
potentially I think your husband's
number one priority is to find his own
replacement and commit to the training
and the quicker he can find his
replacement now this is if the leader
commit agrees to this so if I go help
you find the right person to replace me
and I help with the training and we get
that person there then I'd like to leave
earlier if we get it there I think
that's the only way to short uh to
shorten the 12 months
and I would try that if it were me I
would be trying to advance my leaving
but doing it in an honorable way that
fulfills the need
that I am creating but if you want to
hold me to it I'm going to go ahead and
give you my notice now that on that day
I'm gone that's fair yeah and that's
kind of how it where it's at right now
um how would you handle him so he's
asked for Less responsibility but he's
been given the opposite they've just
piled stuff on him and made his job more
stressful no I'm not again I refuse to
accept the major responsibility I didn't
promise you that that's a separate
conversation I would be here yeah that's
just a boundary issue compensation
during this five years has not increased
by much it doesn't matter so it yeah it
doesn't matter
he's going to be there a year because he
promised he would be
okay and it's bothering him and it's
bothering them and there's a little more
depth to all of this than I'm getting in
this call that I can't see behind the
curtain I can feel it's there but I
don't know what else is going on here
exactly
um but anyway the personal aspect of it
is yeah yeah I think there's some
personal relationships here I think
there's some personal relationships that
are weaving into this as well and so
anyway
um no I'm not taking any more
responsibility I'm going to fulfill my
word I'm not going to run your whole
business for you
that wasn't what I told you I would do I
told you I wouldn't quit for five years
and I'm not going to quit I'm going to
give you my notice now at the five-year
Mark I'll be my last day I'm done
um in the meantime I'm going to do the
exact job description that you told me
to do and I'm not going to work more
hours and I'm not going to take on more
responsibility for the same money if you
want to do that you need to hire
somebody else and um but that you know
that's fair you're keeping
you know you're keeping your work
playing through
um and I think you need I think he wants
to do that you just don't want him to
this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five Ken Coleman Ramsay personality
number one best-selling author host of
the Ken Coleman show is my co-host
thanks for joining us Sam is going to
start this hour off in Houston Texas hey
Sam how are you
hey Devin doing well how are you better
than I deserve what's up
so I have a question here I'm on the
baby step six right now and it's time to
kind of pay off the house but I kind of
have one issue
um it kind of throws a little twist in
there so I have the emergency fund set
aside but have about twenty thousand
dollars
but I know my HVAC in furnace is
extremely old and it may not have too
much longer and so I was wondering
should I continue to pile money into the
emergency fund and keep it in a money
market account or should I just start
putting anything over that 20 grand into
uh into the house
uh you gotten a bid on the HVAC
replacement yet
I did uh I thought it actually had uh
had gone out about a month or so ago uh
and that's when they came and told me
that both of them were over a decade old
um that was kind of expected when I
bought the house I kind of had to do
everything got it to rerun everything
but uh at this point I've had a couple
issues with the uh the AC itself
um and so I'm just not sure what to do I
know based on the baby steps I should be
paying directly what was the instrument
on the HVAC
I think it was 17-5 yeah I'd Paula you
need more than 20 in your emergency fund
then
you back you basically need your
emergency fund plus an HVAC fund
yeah that's what I was thinking but
um I mean I could be wrong but I think
the baby sets is just uh what six months
of uh expenses on the high end no no no
no the baby steps is three to six months
of expenses for your emergency fund this
is really not an emergency
this is my heating and air is going to
go bad and I'm saving up to pay for it
this is a separate savings account this
is like I'm saving up for Christmas
okay it's different than the emergency
fund
okay so should I not put any money
towards the house until I have uh
another 20 kind of put aside yeah yeah
you should you should wait on extra on
the house until you get ready for this
because otherwise we can predict what's
going to happen you're going to have
three thousand dollars left after you
take 20 out of your emergency fund to
fix your heat and air because you didn't
prepare for it
okay right and we don't want to be there
yep
yeah so we might as well actually plan
this
and soon what do you make a year what's
your household income
I make 200. okay so pretty quickly
you're going to have 17 and you know
what I would just go ahead and replace
it
okay so so you would do before it
actually dies yeah
um yeah okay because here's the other
thing it probably sucks it's probably
not very energy efficient it's probably
wrong you know ancient you know it's
antique stuff on there like you said 10
15 years old which is an antique eating
there and so you could put a more
efficient higher sear uh unit on there
and you know you're gonna have a better
situation in the house a better uh your
utility bill is probably going to go
down
um and you don't have this thing glaring
over you this monster just waiting to
break it exactly the wrong time and you
can't get a worker out there and all
that kind of stuff yeah save up 17 and
then fix it oh by the way get more than
one bid yeah
yeah I'd say two or three I I sometimes
I'm not saying this is the case Dave but
sometimes they're not as bad the report
on these things is not as bad as it
seems you know I've had multiple people
come in and look at stuff before and one
guy said I'd replace this tomorrow if it
were me then another honest guy comes
and goes you know what you probably
easily got a year left on this and and
that gives you the time to cash flow it
yeah get multiple opinions on this just
like you would on a medical issue well
and and you know multiple opinions about
what to put in do we put in a Bentley or
do we put in a Chevrolet yeah you know
there's you can paint and air systems
they can
you can put all kinds I just replaced
one of mine it wasn't anywhere close to
17. it was way less than that yeah
exactly Catherine's with us in Richmond
Virginia hi Catherine how are you
hi Dave how are you doing better than I
deserve what's up
so um
I am in a business with my family my
grandmother wanted to give to me and my
seven cousins our real estate business
where we bought different houses and
this happened about 10 years ago
um she gifted it to us when I was in
college my brother runs it
he um is in charge of all the finances
and everything and I want out I don't
know anything that's going on with the
business
um I don't know any houses
um
why do you not know I'm well
because at the time I was I was 20 I
didn't ask a lot of questions how old
are you now
I'm 30. okay well that's 10 years ago
you had 10 years to get caught up to
speed why do you not know right um well
actually I I was working at a real
estate right after college I was working
at Real Estate Management business and I
got the owner to kind of help me
communicate with my
um with my other my cousins and my
brother about the situation and
um I we got in a fight about it and
um
what was the fight about
you asked for information on the
business on the business that you owned
part of and he didn't want to tell you
I asked for the income expense
statements
um I tried to say you know like this is
a business not like a family matter but
he tried to make it you know an
emotional Family Matter
how long ago was that
that was um
so what'd you do you just got a little
quiet Mouse I sat there for seven years
on your angst I did I tried to yes I did
okay so what are you gonna do now I
tried to get my grandma involved what
are you gonna do now I don't know that's
why I'm why I'm calling the show okay
so you don't know how to get out
procedurally
or are you trying to ask for emotional
advice on this
uh procedurally and how to communicate
well about you know I'm a teacher I
don't know anything about business
really
or how to run a business or about real
estate I mean my husband and I own a
house but
um I don't know anything about LLC or
okay I I have do you talked to your
brother now otherwise
yes
for like Christmas you'll see him
yes and you just don't say anything you
just he just has bullied his way and put
you in the corner
Blossom had a conversation with him
about it was a year ago on a family trip
um I was like Hey like how's
this going
um is there any chance that I could you
know see the financials that we could
have this conversation again
um and have it not be an emotional thing
but as a co-business owner and as like a
partner in this LLC all together
um I need to you know I'm really busy he
owns another business local business and
um he told me about your brother's a
turd all right hold on a minute we'll
take you through this break we're gonna
come back and talk to you about how to
deal with your brother oh my gosh this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsay personality is my co-host
today we're talking with Catherine in
Richmond Virginia her grandmother opened
a real estate business for her and her
brother and her cousins seven of them in
total and
um
they um her brother runs it and has not
giving her any reports and we'll tell
her anything about it for a decade and
she wants out is that a first summary of
what you told me so far
that's correct okay you didn't put any
money on this your grandmother funded
all of it and handed it to you and your
cousins
yes how much is all of this worth do you
guess
um there's about four or five
residential houses at the time they were
worth 100 to 200 000 they're probably
worth
300 to 400 now okay and so I think
they're about all paid for okay and so
your part is a half million dollars give
or take
okay possibly yeah something like that
are they Distributing income to you guys
no
so you've not seen a dime out of it
he runs it all the money comes back into
his management fees and nothing goes
back out to you guys at all and so all
you have is this Phantom thing that's
happening over here and you have
absolutely no control over how old is
your grandmother
she is
oh
and she has no Authority anymore she
just simply gave it to all seven of you
and she stepped out or does she have any
say in anything
I tried to involve her one time and um
she they kind of just brushed her off I
mean I think she's
old enough to the point where
um
you're not um hyper assertive as a
matter of fact you're on the other end
of the assertive scale is your husband
an assertive person
he's more assertive than I am yes okay
because here's you know you've got three
options as I can see it
and then you need to decide on one of
these three and then quit worrying about
it drop it
okay okay option number one is continue
what you're doing and just let your
brother run it and just forget it and
not not think another thing about it and
someday they'll need your signature
okay okay and whatever just don't worry
about it okay I don't like that option
you don't like that option that's why
you called but that is an option okay
another option uh is uh scorched Earth
and that is uh you and your husband sit
down with your brother
uh call him for an appointment if he
won't give you one then you're gonna
have to write him a certified letter and
your husband can do the talking and you
say here's what it sounds like we have
tried repeatedly to get reports from you
to find out where the cash flow is going
from these properties you're not doing
anything and you say we don't trust you
you turn this into this it's not any of
that this business is being run very
poorly because the stakeholders are
getting no information this is an
improper way to run a business and we
want out and you're going to buy us out
right now
and you're going to show us the
valuations and based on that you're
going to buy us out and if you do not do
that we're going to hire an attorney and
the circuit judge will force you to buy
us out we will disband this horrible
partnership that your grandmother put
together it's a nightmare
now that one sounds kind of fun the
downside is is that you probably lose
your brother in the process
right but you probably lost him anyway
because he's a turd
to an extent yeah no he is no he is I
mean there's no question about it I mean
he's a complete bully he has pushed you
into the corner and he's done that since
you were a tiny child and he's continued
to do it in your adulthood and he gets
away with it he's a turd okay no
question about it I mean you've told me
like five different ways you've
approached this guy and every time he
just stiff arms you and treats you with
complete disrespect and you know that's
true yeah
I like number two Dave and you haven't
even gotten a number three yet yeah I'm
voting number number three is walk away
and call him and say I'm tired of this I
don't want anything else to do with it I
don't need the money I'm get prepare the
papers I'm going to sign them and indeed
you whatever it is and you can have it
all I don't want any of it screw you
I don't like that one Catherine this is
this is yours how much it is his I don't
like that one I I there's there's a part
of me doesn't like it but there's a part
of it that it's just life goes on
whatever I don't think it's not her
money that's in it her grandmother gave
it to her it's not that it's not it's
not it's found money it's not the end of
the world it's just depends you know
because one way you keep your brother in
the thing I'm not sure you've got much
when you keep him that's what I'm saying
but um I think you take the bully on and
the bully caves he doesn't want to fight
he's just been pushing you away
and and no I'm not going to settle for
seeing the books now they were too late
we've that that that ship has sailed no
you cannot compromise yes you are buying
me out or the judge is going to tell you
to buy me out your decision you have 10
days
so that's a circuit court you have to
file a lawsuit to just to dissolve this
LLC
and you're a stakeholder in the LLC and
then they will have to bring forth
documents that show that you're in
violation of one of those and you're not
this is the you're filing for the
disillusionment of a partnership
he doesn't want that fight I don't think
you're losing anything with him
relationally either and and well you're
not going to be she talked she talks to
him now he won't talk to her again
exactly well well maybe so I mean you
know you need your cut you need your cut
whatever yours is worth and you need to
see the books to get your Cut You Can Be
You Can Be You can no longer be
um any type of wishy-washy about this
you need to make a decision I'm going to
ignore it hold my nose and deal with it
that's the decision and I'm not going to
be stressed about it anymore and then
it's not anybody's fault but mine
because I made this decision to let
these people just run their course
that's one number two I'm going to take
it on full-on frontal right at you we're
going to bring the Bazookas and we're
going to burn this thing to the ground
number three we're just gonna walk away
and we're going to hand you the keys and
you can keep it screw it I don't need it
but make a decision The Angst of 12 or
10 years of you carrying all of this
relational garbage around this whole
deal it is it's been so destructive to
you and to your brother into your
relationship with him
it's a horrible deal
you need to get out of the deal one way
or another
emotionally
um
can I suggest that we sell all the
properties and and resolve it that way
well that's not your option the only
option you've got is they're going to
have to sell something to give you your
cut they may all want to stay together
except you
right you just want out so if they keep
going that's none of your business
right but you're out I want my cut you
need to sell off enough properties to
pay me my cut and you need to show me
proper valuation as to what my
one-seventh is and why and if you don't
give me proof of that we gonna talk to
the judge
okay and it's going to take two years
and twenty thousand dollars worth of
legal fees
oh yeah okay yeah the justice system has
nothing to do with Justice
or efficiency no not at all and so I
sure hope you don't get drug into that I
hope your brother's not that stupid but
he very well could be kind of sounds
like he is
so he didn't have time for a meeting
maybe he doesn't have time for a lawsuit
that's what I believe Dave I I think
that's why I don't have time for a
meeting and not new with his schedule
had to do with anyone deal with her he
does not want to deal with her it's
stiff Army he doesn't want her input he
doesn't want her questioning how he's
doing things and I think this is an easy
out for the bully here he's gotten away
with it for too long he has I think this
is an easy out for him when she goes at
this he's gonna go all right to Jesus
yeah meeting he wants to he wants to get
done with this I think he's gonna yeah I
question out whether or not he's going
to show her the bookstore we get an
honest evaluation oh I can make him do
that too legally all right that's what I
would be I'm a stakeholder yeah I mean
the judge is going to get involved here
if he doesn't play yeah but this is
going to require tremendous like a 10x
assertiveness took for her and her
husband together off of what they have
done so far they're kind of like hey
would you please uh maybe it's like and
he's like nope okay sorry I asked yeah
you know good Lord yeah and the other
good news is you get out of a family
vacation which is always good
That's the Silver Lining here under all
this advice hey Grandma's out there
don't build stuff like this yeah seven
cousins it's crappy wow dumb butt idea
grandma no you're trying to be a
blessing
you screwed this up it's like The
Walton's real estate fun good night Jim
Bob
not Mary Ellen no Mary Ellen you can't
see the bugs
huge swath of our audience has no idea
what we're even talking about right
there all right
this is the Ramsay chef
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today
in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the
debt free stage Doug is with us hi Doug
how are you good Dave and Ken thank you
for having me absolutely where do you
live I live in Raritan New Jersey it's
about 20-25 minutes uh north of
Princeton wonderful good to have you
welcome to Nashville and here to do a
debt free scream how much did you pay
off I paid off a little over 88 000 good
for you and how long did this take you
uh 31 months good for you and your range
of income during that year and a half so
start about two and a half years uh 25
to 50 000 with the uh full-time ends
just side hustles whoa what do you do
for a living So currently I work two
jobs I work as a food delivery driver
for GrubHub and then I do Amazon uh
during like late nights okay so you're
busting it but just to get her done okay
what kind of debt was the 88 000. all
student loans whoa kick Sallie Mae out
Sallie Mae is out of there done with old
Sally what was it the degree for uh I
went for music performance okay um I
didn't necessarily use the degree during
my debt free Journey but I just I got
sick and tired of just you know being in
debt and just kicked it yeah okay good
for you what's your long-term career
goal uh my long term is definitely
um pursuing some kind of teaching in
music
um I know during this journey I got into
accounting so that's something I'm
definitely looking forward to
um go towards but music is definitely
going to be my number one passion gotcha
okay good for you so what started you on
this idea you want to be out of debt 31
months ago uh 2020 covid that'll do it
that was definitely my wake-up call and
um even like way before back in 2015 my
stepfather at the time he introduced me
to your material it was pretty much like
YouTube format
um and then in 2020 I started um
realizing that you had a
a format through Spotify so I just you
know went to your show and listened to
like all the um the episodes and the
debt free screams
um and that's like when I got connected
to uh Ken Coleman John uh John deloney
George Campbell and all the other
personalities as well so
um just going through the Journey it's
been like you know going through all the
uh the podcasts and just you know being
encouraged through that and
um yeah and it was actually the summer
of 2020 that I really started to you
know stay focused in terms of paying off
the debt
um and GrubHub that was the uh the food
delivery um
a service that I worked for and still do
and so that was just working that like
40 you know 50 hours a week and on top
of like my other job uh for Amazon that
was really
um like the two jobs that really were
like lucrative during that time well
I've forgotten all the stupid phrases we
had what was it shelter in place right
yep is that what it was called yeah so
GrubHub was like a lifesaver because
people were told not to leave their
homes because they were going to die
yeah right fed a lot of hungry people
yeah yeah man that's a that was a great
service to be in very good how many
hours were you pulling
uh there were several weeks I was like
50 to like 60 hours yeah for about a
little over a year and a half kept on
hustling yeah yeah so just hustle and
grind knock it out hustle and grind my
parents were very gracious for me you
know living with them I Am The
Stereotype living with my like under my
mom's basement so
you got yeah caught up in that rant a
while ago no that's not you would
yeah
yeah
I was working yeah you're working all
the time that's right so yeah there's no
shame in that man especially when you're
getting out of debt there's no shame in
that well and it's a temporary thing
it's a method it's a method out yeah
that's good yeah you're you were not
Uber aiming at we're very many people
that weren't working if I were calling
yeah
yeah that's funny though you were
sitting there while we did all that uh
all right so what is the secret to
paying off 88 000 in 31 months
know that there you um
you can't put hope in the wrong things
and I know especially with the student
loan crisis and like what's going on
with that
um you just you cannot depend on the
government or just other people in
general to take care of your problems I
know there are many there were many
nights I had to look in the mirror and
say that you know I am the problem and
the past mistakes I've made I mean I've
you know come out from an abusive
relationship I came out in an addiction
I struggled with for half my life like
13 years wow
um and how you phrase how long have you
been dry
I've been driving for a little over a
month and a half now good for this very
recent diet good for you that's awesome
I'm proud of you good work thank you
um and so yeah it was just I know my mom
and I we got really connected during
that time of just me getting out of debt
we watched a lot of
um uh sermons like Billy Graham sermons
and just listen to them all kinds of
like choirs and everything and just know
that you know people like me who are
single and just know who think that they
just can't get who can't make it
um
know that there's hope and especially in
Jesus Christ because him as my lord and
savior he has just done so much for me
and my family that I just I cannot thank
him enough for getting me I just could
not do it without him amen the strength
that he's given me is just I they were
nice that I just I I feel like I
couldn't couldn't make it anymore and
just putting my hope in him it just
really it really um it really helped me
you've done a lot of work in the last 31
months and not just delivering groceries
a lot of personal work well done yeah it
was a financial Journey for sure but a
lot of it was like character development
and just you know going in and turns
into a spiritual journey spiritual
journey as well
um during that time actually I did
create a playlist
um essentially it's just called a debt
free playlist
um it's just a playlist to you know get
people motivated and just you know know
that that there's hope during this
journey so good for you man well done
very well done hey we got a copy of
Total Money Makeover for you in the live
and give bundle as well as the baby
steps millionaires that's the next
chapter in your story thank you I got a
feeling when you've laid a foundation
here during this 31 months it's going to
allow you to do a whole lot of wonderful
things in your life spiritual Foundation
a financial Foundation an emotional
Foundation you're dry for a month and a
half this is good it's good work thank
you very good work and of course also
we've got a one-year subscription or one
year membership to Financial Peace
University go through the details there
you don't have to watch the cheap
YouTube you can watch the real thing
yeah and yeah we'll line you up on all
of that and you use it or give it away
and whatever whatever you need to do
very very well done and way to go mom
cheering him on and giving him some
support along the way that's good that's
good work that's not that's not a bad
type of support that's not enabling
that's um that's lifting there's a
difference how about a shout out to to
uh Billy Graham you know a lot of young
people wouldn't it wouldn't hurt you to
watch some Billy Graham on YouTube you
might be surprised that's awesome it
wouldn't hurt old people either well
that's well that too yeah I'm telling
you that's awesome stuff proud of you
good stuff Doug thank you very very cool
very proud you're a hero man good work
how's it feel to be free it feels
awesome yeah yeah oh man onward and
upward now yep is it worth all that
struggle when you stand right there
right now it was it is and I just I yeah
I mean I'm just speechless right now
yeah good for you good for you all right
Doug from Newark New Jersey area 88 000
paid off in 31 months did it delivering
25 to 50 000 income 60 to 80 hours a
week count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one I'm dead free
wow
that's how it's done ladies and
gentlemen
beautifully done I love it
well folks Financial Peace University is
on sale right now we got the old Black
Friday special going on that the
cheapest the lowest price we've ever
done
59.99 you can sign up for Financial
Peace University
this is the nine-week class that 10
million people have gone through and
learned how to handle money get out of
debt Bill wealth be outrageously
generous and get hope and get Freedom
two words that most people don't grasp
around money it's possible Financial
Peace two words that don't go together
like Airline service so check it out
guys get FPU of 59 go to
ramseysolutions.com give FPU that's a
chance for you to sign up for yourself
and or give it to someone else you can
buy as many as you want at 59 they make
great gifts to give away we'll send you
the membership and you can make that a
stocking stuffer some of you spend more
than this on Pizza this is a
life-changing nine weeks of lessons
Financial Peace University
ramseysolutions.com give
FPU this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
omy 4 9 only be careful and watch
yourselves closely so that you do not
forget the things your eyes have seen or
let them fade from your heart as long as
you live teach them to your children and
to their children after them agathi
Christie said one does not doesn't
recognize the really important moments
in life of one's life until it's too
late this is true blinds.com question of
the day they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee means even if you mismeasure
you pick the wrong color they'll remake
your blinds for free you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use the promo code Ramsay to
get the best possible deal today's
question comes from Thomas in Missouri
as a Christian I feel like I have a duty
to take care of my employees I have a
small business with nine employees they
currently make minimum wage if I were to
raise their wages to a living wage then
my profit margin would decrease this is
a business I worked really hard at for
so many years I think God would want me
to benefit from my hard work now what
should I do
uh okay
this is an onion here Dave
um number one
um businesses deal with this all the
time and when they when they raise wages
they have a decision to make do you want
your profit margin to stay the same and
so if so then you have to raise your
costs and you have to weigh that with
the marketplace and what your customers
will or will not pay and this is the
this is the dance that a lot of small
business people have to deal with and
have had to deal with and been heard
from it so I don't think it's a choice
here between God wants you to benefit
from your hard work now and you know not
doing what you want to do which is pay
your employees more I think you can do
both but you're going to have to
square raising some prices or cutting
costs in other areas if that's even an
option this is hard to answer I want to
say that everything I just said it's
very difficult to answer that via a
static question where we can't answer a
lot of questions excuse me ask more
questions yeah the buzzword that's the
problem in this is living wage and who
determines that yeah well I can tell you
who determines it me right that's my
point not what I'm saying no I'm the
employer here's the thing okay if I pay
12 an hour
or if I pay whatever you want to
whatever minimum wage is in your area
okay and
um
a guy comes in and you do a budget on
the guy and he has five kids and uh he
needs ninety thousand dollars a year to
pay his bills and feed his kids
um I can't as a Christian hire him for
that job
because I can't pay him ninety thousand
dollars to do that job and ninety
thousand dollars for him is a living
wage because that's what it takes to
feed his five kids
okay if I have a
19 year old who lives with her his
parents comes in and is looking for
part-time work
and um any money he makes is going in
his pocket because he has basically no
personal overhead and twelve dollars an
hour is what I can afford as the
employer then that is his living wage
so this idea that there is a uh a
universal living wage is absolute horse
crap there is no such thing because it
takes some families it takes families in
different situations in different
locales a different amount to live it
takes a family of four more to live in
Manhattan than it does in Nashville
so the living wage would be different
for a family of four or a family of one
or a family of 14. the living wage
changes on that and so what we do at
Ramsey as Christians we have a
responsibility to take care of our
employees and one of the
responsibilities is not hiring someone
who can't afford to live on what we are
paying for that position
so you are disqualified if you can't
make it on what we are paying for that
position
regardless of if you want the job or
you're qualified for the job we will run
a budget with you because we care about
you and it is our responsibility once
you are here to make sure you are cared
for and we do take care of our team
beyond measure we take care of our team
that's correct way beyond measure we
take care of our team but we do not hire
people who cannot afford to live on
what we pay for that position yeah and
that is our responsibility that's your
responsibility so you know well you know
we have one lady go well you know based
on your inappropriate requests for my
personal budget information I'm going to
withdraw my name from future future
employment consideration to which we
said people that talk like that don't
even work here so we're not doing you
know it's great see you goodbye you know
don't let the door hit you in the butt
you know it's good you know we don't
need you and but you know but the reason
for the inappropriate request of the
personal information is to protect you
from you because some people will take a
job that they can't afford to live on
the income because they're so desperate
for a job right and uh so but this idea
that there's some kind of generic living
wage out there floating around that you
have a moral obligation to that's a
singer singular number is absolute horse
crap so uh you're paying minimum wage
for nine employees are any of them
trying to actually live on that with a
family if so why did they take that job
or why did you hire them into some thing
they can't afford to live on
and that's a bigger question then do you
raise your wages to meet this right and
here's the other thing you have to have
to look at your business model and the
market and go based on whatever product
or service I am selling because it's one
of the two this is what the market will
allow me to do and I may not ever be
able to truly have all nine of them on
what would be called a full living wage
you might be in the hourly space and
that's what you have and thus you've got
turnovery of younger people working for
it that's just part of your business I
gotta come in today instead of company
offered him eighty thousand dollars more
to do the exact same thing he's doing
with us and we said fantastic help you
pack your desk yeah it's a no-brainer we
cannot we cannot make a return on paying
you eighty thousand dollars more than
you're being paid now so you uh you're
gonna be working it's a new place my
friend and we'll help you go
um because this you know we have to make
a return on investment here or the rest
of the team doesn't eat right because
their checks don't clear there's a
responsibility all the way around so yes
God would want you to take care of your
team and he would want you to benefit
from your hard work now these are not
incompatible that's correct yes they're
not incompatible that's correct that's
the point of it and don't fall into this
socialistic living wage crap that was
Karl Marx that was not Jesus okay
there's a difference open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Julia is with us in Sacramento hi
Julia how are you
hi good how are you it's a pleasure
same here how can we help
my mom recently purchased a timeshare in
Mexico and she paid cash for it
and
me to give her my ID and my birth
certificate
she wants to modify her trust no
I don't want a timeshare
it's legalized fraud you're gonna get
this is not a blessing this is a curse
why would a loving mother do this to her
daughter because she still thinks it's a
good deal she got screwed no we don't
need to pass this on this is not an
heirloom
yeah she thinks it's a good deal it's
not a good deal it's a horrible deal
there are no good timeshares they suck
100 of them it is one of the worst
products ever put out by man
I hope I wasn't unclear
I thought so as well
in my ear he was clear don't make him
say no a third time Julia
yeah just lovingly kindly mom I I'm not
interested in the timeshare thank you
though
okay I don't I don't I I think they're a
really bad deal and I'm really sorry you
bought one mom
and I think you're gonna regret it and
I'd never ever ever ever wanted in my
name no thank you thank you thank you no
I also don't want your dog to bite me
you know this is like
these are let me tell you there's a 97
dissatisfaction rate with timeshare
owners
there's no other product out there in
the world that has a 97 dissatisfaction
rate people that buy them hate them
they're a complete screw job your poor
precious mother got screwed over and
hasn't realized it yet and she's trying
to pass that on as an heirloom
[Music]
it's for you believe me we wish you
really do that's the gift that keeps on
giving there
[Music]
show kid thanks for having me hey Laura
I'm
Zach Andrew James everybody in the booth
good work you guys very well very good
job the booth people
that puts this hour in the books we'll
be back with you before you know it in
the meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus with the Ramsay
Network app on your smartphone it's the
only place to listen to the entire back
catalog of episodes download the Ramsay
Network app in your favorite app store
today
foreign
[Music]